just 10 miles down the road from where
dante wright was killed the derrick
chauvin trial continues today with the
defense set to present
its arguments yesterday chauvin's
attorney raised concerns over
how the brooklyn center on rest could
affect the jury jimmy yukis is outside
the courthouse in minneapolis for us
jamie good morning to you
good morning tony after more than two
weeks the prosecution
is expected to rest its case today
yesterday prosecutors focused on
appealing to the jury's emotions
and put george floyd's younger brother
on the stand
he just knew how to make people feel
better
heartbreaking testimony from george
floyd's younger brother
filonas he showed us like
how to treat our mom and how to respect
our mom
he he just he loved her so
dearly i miss both of them
jurors listened as he described growing
up with his big brother
and the joy he brought their family he
was
so much of a leader to us he used to
make the best
banana mayonnaise sandwiches and he used
to make cereal sandwiches
because george couldn't cook cbs news
legal analyst ricky clemens says the
younger floyd was used as what's called
a spark of life witness
meant to show the jury just how much
george floyd's life
impacted others i think george floyd's
brother
influenced the jury in all kinds of ways
this is obviously very very painful for
him and for his family
and jurors are people they can feel that
kind of pain
earlier on the stand cardiologist
jonathan rich echoed previous testimony
and said george floyd's heart stopped
because of low oxygen levels
caused by ex-officer derek chovin's
actions
before the trial resumed monday the
defense asked to sequester the jury
because of the fatal police shooting of
dante wright i think
brings it to the forefront of the jury's
mindset
that a verdict in this case
is going to have consequences but the
judge denied the motion
a move ricky clemen disagrees with they
can't get away from it when they go to
the courthouse and they can't get away
from it when they go home
it seems the only reasonable thing to do
would have been to have sequestered them
on monday
the defense is expected to begin part of
the case today it's not clear how many
people
it'll call to testify or if chauvin
himself will take the stand
the judge told the jury it should expect
closing arguments
this coming monday and jurors will be
sequestered once deliberations begin
anthony jamie yukas in minneapolis
thanks jamie